so I moved into a leadership role at the
Edmonton Police Service which is a
Canadian Police Department about 10
years ago and since then I've been
handling quite a few projects a lot of
projects
but after it completed the PMP
certification from Simply learn I
started looking at things kind of in a
different way and I started asking the
right questions I found and those skills
came into play even after I retired a
few months ago
hi my name is Darwin Lee and I live in
Edmonton Alberta in Canada and I took
early retirement from the Edmonton
Police Service because I wanted to
pursue my passion for helping people
find relief Financial Freedom and to
create generational wealth I got
promoted to a program manager position
with the city of Edmonton and for that I
needed the PMP certification and the
time frame in which I needed to get this
certification was very small it was
quite short not going to lie and at
first I just started with a course that
I found online with the with a different
website a different service but let's
just say the experience wasn't that good
and I could get through a single unit
without a whole bunch of issues and so
finally I started the PMP certification
course with simpler and that helped
tremendously I've been on projects my
whole career but the skills that I
acquired from the course really helped
me you know not only my projects but to
support all the project managers that
reported to me or that I worked with
the course was comprehensive
well-structured the study notes were
excellent and all of these things really
helped me to be able to retain the
information and so because of the course
I was able to understand the status of
the projects we had on the go and new
projects that were that were coming very
clearly and I was able to make
recommendations much more quickly and
and many of my peers were not able to do
that kind of in the same way in the same
level among all the other features I
think the study guides were something
that really helped me the most really
prepared me for Learning and for the for
the PMP certification test there was one
ongoing project in particular at work
where we were facing a lot of issues and
I was able to come in and help to
streamline things and I realized that I
was asking the questions that were
straight straight out of the training
I've since retired from the city of
Edmonton and my it career and right now
I'm in the process of planning a
conference it's a project that I'm
pursuing at the moment so I'm continuing
to directly apply my project management
skills it's more competitive nowadays in
the workforce and so everyone has to
find a way to differentiate themselves
and have a phrase on your own time and
on your own time and although
organizations should be paying for for
your skills and supporting you
nonetheless I think it's our job to keep
up Skilling ourselves on our own time
and on our own dining